this is something that I've actually
relied on a little bit myself whenever I
get to a low point where I think why do
I even bother I just remind myself this
is where most people stop and this is
why they don't win and this relates to
another one which is a reminder for the
Gladiators in the arena who feel beat up
and scarred with no hope in sight
building a business is hard hard feels
shitty this is what hard feels like and
this is why most people can't do it but
you can this is what hard feels like
is so [__] nice to lean on it is so
nice to lean on take me through that low
points there's actually a story I'm
getting a little Goosebumps telling that
so
um I was way back in my day
um like you a party party promoter but I
was in a fraternity so I was president
of fraternities yeah and this was my
first semester being president and so
you have a pledge class you get two
pledge classes as a person you get a
fall in a spring and then that's your
your tenure and then another president
comes in and what we knew and this would
be really interesting for the audience
from a human behavior perspective is
that like clockwork
every time we start a new pledge class
within 14 days 10 to 14 it was like
clockwork they would all get together
and they'd revolt and they'd say we
don't want to do it anymore this isn't
what we signed up for this is way
[__] harder than we thought it was
going to be like we thought we were just
gonna party with you guys like that's
what we expected which also shows you
how long it takes people to adapt or
acclimate to a very a significantly more
difficult situation right
I'll tell you what happens after and
then I'll tell you what happened in
between
after we have this kind of talk that we
had and I'll tell you how I how I
explained it when I was President
um all of a sudden it all vanishes
because their expectations of reality
have completely reset we break reality
like in the first 10 to 14 days it's so
painful for them because it's such a
contrast
not the fun stuff but what's not fun oh
my God I mean they can't drink can't
talk to girls the only people they could
talk to are brothers or each other and
we're mean to them so they could really
only talk to each other and the whole
point here is that we're trying to get
them close together because there's a
bunch of dudes who don't know each other
from different parts of the campus right
and we have to get them in eight to
twelve weeks to leave as one unit of
people who know everything about one
another that trust one another that know
everything of the other people in the
house so it's like how do you do that
well there's only x amount of
communication you can have every day so
let's cut out anybody who's not us okay
and then if we really want them to be
close together we'll also reinforce that
we're mean but part of what they had to
do is they had to learn everything about
everyone else in the house and so every
pledge has to do something that would
impress a brother and then they get a
signature from their brother being like
I approve of you and you have to get
every single brother's signature by the
time you're done right and so that's
where each of those side quests become
as insane as you might imagine right and
there's lots of you know there was lots
of hazing back in the day which is not
fun and you know a lot of sleepless
nights and things like that and you go
from like parting with girls like your
top of the world all these brothers
feeding you drinks being like be like
you're awesome dude to then like the
next day and this is literally how it
happens this is how like the break in
reality happens we do this huge party to
like launch the new class and the next
morning they all wake up they're all
like they all sleep at the house because
that's one of the requirements
and they're all hungover and got their
ties like vomit in the corner or
whatever and we're like great clean it
up and they're like what because up to
this point they haven't cleaned after a
party because all they did is got to
party see the girls and then leave
but then all of a sudden they're like
mopping bottom in the corner and they're
hungover and they feel terrible and
they're like what the [__] this is what
I signed up for right so anyways two
weeks of this they get together and they
wanted me to meet them and this always
happens because they want to meet on
their their Turf and I'm like all right
guys what's up and so it's just me all
right and my vice president and like 25
guys so there's like a you know there's
like a size comparison of like
just animalistically there's way more of
them than there is of me
and so I just asked them a couple
questions I was like
who here before pledging started was
like I want to be a part of this house
the guys are like you know me okay like
okay got it
who here thought it was going to be easy
all right who here thought it would be
hard
they raised their hands I'm like guys
this is what hard feels like
and all of a sudden there's just like
this big exhale in the room they're like
expectations get reset this is normal
you wanted this thing you expect it to
be hard reality now matches conditions
so our expectations now match conditions
this is what heart feels like
and then all of a sudden it's like they
got permission to feel shitty and by
getting permission to feel shitty they
stop feeling shitty because they're like
this is just my new world
and so then you know you're like listen
you give eight weeks you're gonna get
three and a half years other people are
going to drive you around late at night
other people want to clean after you
like it's a good investment right and
that it was a good deal like you give
one semester and you get the rest of
them to just do whatever you want
um
but that concept like that quote on both
of those came from that experience of
having someone tell me this is what
heart feels like
this is where most people stop and this
is why they don't win is also another
beautiful bit of motivation and given
that I spent a little bit of time with
Goggins and cam Hanes two guys I was
telling you about this before you said
must be nice as we walked in so Cameron
Haynes Beau Hunter extraordinaire lives
in Oregon and he has behind the power
Rack in his garage where he left he has
must be nice written and I was like why
why have you got that put up on there
and he was like it's because everyone
says it must be nice to be you Cam must
be nice to be sponsored by height and
all of these like top level bow things
and go on Rogan he was uh there was a
video that went super viral of Goggins
losing his [__] after Jon Jones won last
weekend uh and the guy that he's hugging
his cam so it's like it must be nice for
you to be backstage at UFC must be nice
for this and I've seen what that guy
does and that guy picks up a rock that
weighs about 80 pounds and it's got the
word poser written on the front of it
because people call him the poser and he
carries it up a hill that is Maybe
like a thousand foot of elevation mile
and a half high with no Fanfare at the
end no Finish Line doesn't post it on
social media unless the team's there
filming it with someone else and then
carries it back down puts it in the boot
of his Raptor drives away and he just
does that because he needs to remind
himself that he's doing the stuff that
is hard and this is where most people
stop and this is why they don't win
combined with this is what hard feels
like justifies things being hard now
I do worry and I find this in myself
sometimes as well that you can
be so good at dealing with suffering
that you can actually push yourself a
little bit too far and you go I'm
starting to Bear more burden than I can
basically take on and the Art of not
burning out is something that I think a
lot of people if you if this resonates
with you
the art of not burning out is something
that you really really need to be able
to feel and like realizing what happens
when you just start to glance off the
bottom side of it and go okay like I'm
just gonna ease off the gas so that I
need to take this afternoon to go sauna
and get some sunshine and chill out and
get some food and then I can put my foot
back on maybe a little bit tomorrow and
we'll temper it
um but just it it justifies the fact
that
I use this stat all the time 90 of
podcasts don't make it past episode
three and of the 90 of the 10 that do 90
don't make it past episode 20. so by
making 21 podcasts you're in the top
percentile of all podcasters ever in
history
that's what hard feels like and that's
not even hard it's just consistent [__]
me it's less than half a year yeah
insane I hear stats like that and I just
think man it is so easy to win
like that I mean like when I hear that
that's exactly what I think I'm just
like man
for everyone's like struggling to win
it's like you like most of the pain that
people experience is purely in their own
minds we'll get back to talking to Alex
in one second but first I need to tell
you about HubSpot 28 of some people's
weeks are spent reading deleting and
sorting emails which means that very
much email is not dead starting an email
newsletter means that you've got direct
connection with your audience it means
that you actually own your audience it
is the only way that you can own them
without going through a third party like
a social media platform and from HubSpot
right now you can download their free
email template that will teach you how
to make your own newsletter you can
learn how to build an amazing email
newsletter from scratch that will check
out a compiled lookbook of awesome
examples from real Publications you can
learn what it takes to create a
successful email newsletter with
exceptional design unique and compelling
copy clickable calls to action and
excellent user experience and there is a
step-by-step guide about how to get your
newsletter launched so if you've been
thinking I want to start doing a
newsletter this sounds cool this sounds
like a good way for me to start writing
to build an audience that I can then
sell two or it can then move to other
platforms as well this is a fantastic
place to begin all that you need to do
to download this free guide that will
take you from no email newsletter to a
fantastically designed email newsletter
using industry inside information all
that you need to do is head to
clickhubspot.com Modern wisdom that's
clickhubspot.com modern wisdom to
download your free email template today
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]